[Applause]
2019 must feel like a long time ago for
boris john election one convincingly by
boris johnson
back then he swept to power with a huge
majority
of 80 mps but fast forward a few years
and his position is looking far less
comfortable regretfully i have to say
that his position is no longer 10
probably the third strike and i'd say
that with a heavy heart i understand
that people
across the country are
angry
after a series of scandals over mp's
lobbying the downing street flat
refurbishment a peppa pig world speech
peppa pig world is is very much my kind
of place uh
forgive me and apparently a lot of
lockdown parties his defense that he
didn't realize he was at a party
it is so ridiculous he started to lose
support from some of his mps so could he
be replaced and how would that work
you could be forgiven for having a sense
of deja vu here a change of leadership
in the conservative party now will put
our country's future at risk it's not
been too long since tory mps held a vote
of no confidence in their leader are you
confident
in 2018 theresa may's bungled handling
of the brexit negotiations led to a
challenge from her own party the result
of the ballot
held this evening is that the
parliamentary party
does have confidence
she survived that contest but her
premiership didn't last too much longer
and she resigned in 2019 rather than
face a second confidence vote i will
shortly leave the job that it has been
the honor of my life to hold and who was
waiting in the wings to take over
amongst the field of contenders juan
boris johnson boris johnson is elected
as the leader of the conservative
tory mps who are upset with the party's
leadership can submit no confidence
letters to the 1922 committee
party rules state at least 15 of mps
must write a letter to make a leadership
challenge possible
that means if 54 mp send a letter to
committee chair sir graham brady the
vote of no confidence is triggered
[Music]
a secret ballot would then take place
boris johnson would need
181 of his own tory mps a simple
majority to back him if he succeeded he
would stay as prime minister and be safe
from another vote of no confidence for a
year if he failed there would be a
leadership contest and he would be
barred from standing
an mp needs to be nominated by two
colleagues to enter the leadership
contest if more than two tory mps put
themselves forward and secure the
nominations of two other colleagues a
series of secret ballots will be held to
whittle them down
the individual who receives the fewest
number of votes will be eliminated after
every round until two candidates remain
party members then get to choose between
the final two and the winner gets the
keys to number 10. chancellor how are
you planning to pay for all of this the
favourites to replace boris johnson at
the moment are the chancellor of the
exchequer rishi sunak foreign secretary
liz truss and former health secretary
jeremy hunt anticipating a successful
vote this evening other big names who
could decide to run include dominic rabb
michael gove and pretty patel is this an
audio cabinet home secretary it is not
clear yet there is enough opposition
within boris johnson's party to actually
defeat him in a vote of no confidence if
the scandals keep emerging from number
10 the pressure on boris johnson will
keep growing and if his mps decide their
big political winner is now a big
political liability they know they have
the power to do something about it
[Music]
you